ah I like a man for the next 47 minutes  all that wait wait don't kill me Oh  Sookie I'm not saying anything I believe  it Dom be out of this just like all the  ladies don't leave so I'll be out of it  we should go hang out by the base of the  wolf penis and get struck by lightning  hey that would be something I've always  wanted to see a giant flaming penis you  are so dumb very dumb also a lot of any  ways married Bob you have a girlfriend  I'm all alone wait what kind of Mary  took wait kid wait legit Mary Mary yeah  I got I got the ring on my penis or  [Laughter]  bring it on  this episode will be called a really  long day for wait hey someone took away  this dirt where'd all the dirt go huh I  better check with this dirt over here  oh hey Cho savvy way you choose who you  know Snivy